يمثل اليوم الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب امام المحكمه الفيدراليه بولايه
فلوريدا بعد توجيه 37 تهمه فيدراليه له
على خلفيه حيازه وثائق سريه بعد مغادرته
البيت الابيض وقد تجمع عدد من مناصر ترامب
خارج مقر اقامته في منتجع دورال في ميامي
مرددي ناهوتافات تنادي ببراءه ترامب وتدعو
لقول ما يصفونه بالحقيقه كما دعوا الى
توجيه نفس التهم للرئيس الحالي
[موسيقى]
يعاقب القانون الامريكي بالسجن لفتره
متفاوته على التهم الموجهه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
يسجن لمده اقصاها عشر سنوات من يحتفظ بشكل
متعمد بمعلومات تتعلق بالدفاع الوطني
بالاضافه الى سجن 20 عاما لتهمه المؤامره
لعرقله العداله وبالاحتفاظ بوثائق او
سجلات امريكيه كذلك من يثبت اتهامه بحجم
المستجن المستندات او السجلات والمده
نفسها لما يدان باخفاء مستند او سجلا بشكل
غير امن اما ما يتعلق بالتخطيط لاخفاء
المستندات فيعاقب القانون عليه بالسجن
لمده اقصاها خمس سنوات والمده ذاتها لمن
يدلي باقوال كاذبه